en un vídeo anterior vimos estas
gráficas esto es y es igual a 1 sobre x
cuadrada esto es igual a 1 sobre x y
exploramos cuál es el límite cuando x
tiende a 0 en estos dos escenarios y en
el escenario de la izquierda vimos como
x se vuelve cada vez menos negativa
cuando se acerca más a 0 desde el lado
izquierdo el valor de 1 sobre x cuadrada
no tiene límite hacia la dirección
positiva y pasa lo mismo cuando
aproximamos x desde la derecha cada vez
menos positiva pero sigue siendo
positiva el valor de 1 sobre x cuadrada
no es acotado en la dirección positiva
en el vídeo dijimos que podría decirse
que este límite no es acotado pero lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
introducir una nueva anotación en lugar
de decir simplemente que no es acotado
podríamos decir que desde la izquierda y
desde la derecha parece que vamos al
infinito positivo así que podemos
introducir esta anotación y decir oye
esto va a ir al infinito
y verán que algunas personas llaman a
esto no acotado algunas personas dicen
que no existe porque no se está
acercando a un valor finito mientras que
algunas personas usarán esta anotación
del límite que va al infinito pero qué
pasa con este escenario podemos usar
nuestra nueva anotación aquí bueno
cuando nos acercamos a cero desde la
izquierda parece que no tenemos una
cuota en la dirección negativa y cuando
nos acercamos a cero desde la derecha no
tenemos una cota en la dirección
positiva de modo que aquí no podemos
decir que el límite va hacia el infinito
porque desde la derecha va hacia el
infinito pero desde la izquierda va
hacia menos infinito entonces aquí
seguirías diciendo que este no existe
podrías hacer límites unilaterales aquí
si no estás familiarizado con esto te
animo a que los revises en khan academy
si dijeras el límite de 1 sobre x cuando
x tiende a 0 desde el lado izquierdo de
valores inferiores a 0 bueno entonces
miraría a esto por aquí y dirías que
parece que estamos yendo 5 está en la
dirección negativa por lo que dirías que
esto es igual a menos infinito y por
supuesto si dijeras el límite a medida
que x tiende a 0 desde la derecha de 1
sobre x bueno aquí estamos yendo 5 está
en la dirección positiva de modo que
esto va a ser igual al infinito positivo
hagamos un ejemplo de los problemas de
kant academy con base en esta idea en
esta anotación
de modo que aquí dice considera las
gráficas abc las líneas punteadas
representan a síntomas cual de las
gráficas concuerda con esta proposición
el límite cuando x tiende a 1 de h de x
es igual a infinito pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo muy bien vamos a
revisar cada una de estas gráficas
entonces queremos pensar en qué pasa
cuando x es igual a 1 que está justo
aquí en la gráfica cuando x tiende a 1
dejen de escribir esto para cada una de
las gráficas para la gráfica a el límite
de hd x cuando x tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda parece que no tiene cota en la
dirección positiva es igual a infinito y
el límite de hd x cuando x tiende a 1
desde la derecha bueno parece que va a
ser igual a menos infinito es igual a
menos infinito y como éstas van en
direcciones diferentes
no podrías decir que el límite es igual
a infinito cuando x tiende a 1 desde las
dos direcciones
de modo que yo descartaría esta opción
vamos a ver la opción b cuál es el
límite
vhd x cuando x tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda bueno cuando nos acercamos
desde la izquierda parece que tiende al
infinito positivo y parece que el límite
de hd x cuando x tiende a 1 desde la
derecha también es igual al infinito
positivo y como nos acercamos a la misma
dirección del infinito podrías decir que
b cumple con las restricciones pero
vamos a verificarse para asegurarnos
bueno puedes ver muy claramente a x
igual a 1 entonces cuando nos acercamos
desde la izquierda vamos hacia menos
infinito y cuando nos acercamos desde la
derecha vamos hacia el infinito positivo
por lo que una vez más no se acercan al
mismo infinito por lo que descartamos
también esta opción hasta el próximo
vídeo